[Music]
we all know everyone is beautiful in
their own way but unfortunately Disney
Villains often come with unique features
you just can't ignore talented artists
reimagine them as beautiful and we can't
get enough of Captain Hook's new look
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and give this video a big thumbs up now
sit back and enjoy as we look at ten
Disney Villains reimagined as beautiful
yzma from The Emperor's New Groove let's
start with yzma one of the most unique
looking human characters out there just
like the rest of our beloved Disney
Villains yzma is hungry for power of
money and she loves to plot against
Cusco the main protagonist of the story
she turned into a villain after she gets
fired and since then she is determined
to get revenge on her boss cusco with
this plot it's hard to believe this is a
Disney movie for children right well it
is and many love use left for her
humorous side to her revenge plotting
her looks on the other hand might be
slightly unfortunate
ESMA is tall and very thin she has a
pointy chin big eyes and an even bigger
smile her features aren't highlighted as
exactly pretty but this artist who goes
by the simple nickname J reimagined
useless looks doesn't she look stunning
she still got that unique character vibe
to her but the human version of oozma
looks far less terrifying the artist
managed to take her big eyes and turn
them into the most beautiful eyes you
have ever seen but despite her looks you
can't deny that her character is
hilarious we'd love to see a live action
of the Emperor's New Groove who do you
think could play yzma shun you from
Mulan here's a question for you how many
men does it take to deliver a message
male Disney Villains come in all shapes
and sizes and they're usually much more
intense when it comes to plotting
revenge but the most ruthless villain
out there is Shenmue from Mulan he's
strong confident and extremely
cold-blooded his physical features
aren't doing him any favors either
although he's very muscular he comes
very sharp facial features that aren't
exactly easy on the eye but Jay the
artists we mentioned earlier managed to
turn him into a game of Thrones style
head turner and we love it check out his
impressive makeover although his
features are still sharp this version of
shun you has that majestic look you just
can't help but admire his muscles are
much more sculpted although we do think
that his attitude hasn't changed at all
although the story of Mulan who
challenges gender roles and shun you is
one of those villains that doesn't
underestimate women although we can
imagine he doesn't do this out of
respect Shan Yu is one of the meanest
villains on our list but we can't wait
to show you what other villains look
like with their new Beauty makeover
doctor faciliate from The Princess and
the Frog doctor facili a comes with a
very interesting sidekick he has his own
shadow that has it's very own
personality which is why he's also known
as the shadow man dr. Vasily a wants to
be the wealthiest and most powerful man
in New Orleans and he's determined to
reach his goal dr. Vasily a isn't
exactly a charismatic villain and his
looks aren't doing him any justice he's
tall dark slender and has a tiny
perfectly shaved mustache purple eyes
long bony fingers and a gap in between
his front teeth he's not exactly easy on
the eye is he Jay the artist decided to
give him a makeover and turned him into
a slightly more handsome Disney villain
his outfit is suddenly very stylish
although we love that the artist didn't
change his features the long bony
fingers the moustache the perfect
posture it's all still there what do you
think about this Shadow Man on a scale
of 1 to 10 with 10 being extremely
handsome which number would you give the
new version of dr. priscilly a speaking
of the man do you want to hear an
interesting fan Theory the deviantART
user suspects that the shadow man is
actually Tiana's father James who died
during the war but how would this
villain know of Tianna
if he didn't meet her until the end of
the movie although of course the
characteristics of Tiana's father seem
to differ from doctor phacelia we might
never know if this is true the Queen of
Hearts from Alice in Wonderland although
she has a lovely name the Queen of
Hearts is immature loud and incredibly
cruel which is why she's on the list not
only does she want to behead Alice but
she also wants to rule Wonderland and
make sure everyone obeys her orders the
Queen of Hearts is an obese character
with a gold crown earrings a red
headband and a black and red gown with
black and yellow stripes Alice is quoted
saying that the Queen of Hearts is a fat
pompous bad-tempered old tyrant and well
she's not exactly wrong but crimson
cobwebs from deviantART decided to give
the Queen of Hearts a second chance she
combined the looks of an adult model
Vanessa Lake and the fierce attitude of
the Queen of Hearts
and gave the Disney villain a stunning
makeover
would Alice in Wonderland's story change
if the Queen of Hearts looked like this
or could she still play off the villain
we know and love many confused the Queen
of Hearts with the Red Queen from
through the looking-glass and although
the two share similarities they're not
the same characters we're not sure what
the Red Queen would look like if she
ever got a makeover but our Alice in
Wonderland Queen is totally fabulous
Cruella Deville from 101 Dalmatians
although she's a villain you have to
admit that Cruella De Vil is one of the
most fabulous antagonists ever she's one
of the most iconic Disney villains and
her legacy carried on long after 101
Dalmatians we usually use the karela de
Ville reference for someone who's not
really the nicest person after all Cola
does want the skin of 99 puppies for her
coat Cruella is very slim she usually
dresses way over the top which makes her
negative features stand out that much
more koalas most signature feature is
her long coat which makes her look even
mightier but wait until you see this
version of karela the artist named J
reimagined Cruella into a nicer looking
character and weren't very impressed her
half-black half-white hair is now
beautifully styled and her makeup is
fantastic the artist kept karelas
villain exterior but we have to admit
that she looks much nicer than the
cartoon version speaking of a beautiful
Cruella according to the Internet Movie
Database live-action 101 Dalmatians is
in the works with Emma Stone plain
karela de Ville we can't wait to see it
Claude Frollo from The Hunchback of
Notre Dame The Hunchback of Notre Dom
was released in 1996 which means it
recently celebrated its 20th anniversary
the main antagonist name was Claude
Frollo
and he lusted after Esmeralda just as
much as he lusted after getting rid of
gypsies you might have noticed a trend
with Disney's villains they all seemed
to be very slender and Claude is no
exception he's thin elderly and has pale
skin that's accompanied by an unfriendly
look the artists that simply just called
Jai reimagined Claude into a slightly
less grumpy and better looking person
this version of Claude has a very
mysterious vibe to him and he briefly
looks like he could play a vampire in
Twilight not much has changed from his
original version which can only mean
Claude was just too destructive did you
know that he's actually considered to be
one of the darkest Disney villains of
all time
sometimes it's very hard to believe that
these types of movies were meant for
children we can totally see Claude parry
with dr. facili a these two would
definitely be up to no good
Hades from Hercules Hades might be a
complete opposite of Claude Frollo well
he's still the main antagonist of
Hercules Hades has many funny moments
that easily steal every scene he shows
up and Hades is a Greek god of the
underworld and even though he can be
hilarious he's still a villain in the
story he's a pretty popular character
but let's not forget he did attempt to
steal Mount Olympus from the one and
only Zeus Hades is quite muscular and
has a pretty unique hairstyle his hair
is actually blue fire which turns yellow
when he's angry is Hades your favorite
character wait until you see Jay the
artist impressive illustration can you
say ooh la la
Hades got the best makeover of all the
villains we showed you so far it looks
even more majestic than usual he was
meant to have a similar attitude to
Ursula from The Little Mermaid but the
writers decided to change his character
once James Woods auditioned for the role
if Hades is your favorite Disney villain
you should thank James for auditioning
because otherwise this Greek God would
have had a completely different role in
the movie Ursula from The Little Mermaid
they really weren't kidding when they
called Ursula a witch did you know that
Ursula is not an octopus it might be
hard to believe but if you count the
tentacles you'll notice that she only
has six of them her six tentacles are
there because eight tentacles were a lot
harder to animate so instead of an
octopus Ursula is merely a squid with
six tentacles and you have to admit that
this squid doesn't exactly have many
attractive features she has to alter
egos and she's extremely power hungry
and manipulative her light lavender skin
and the mole on her cheek don't really
do her any justice but neither does her
excessive use of makeup her look was
actually based on a character from the
pink flamingos movie called divine J the
artist gave Ursula a second chance and
reimagined her into one of the most
remarkable characters we have adverse
scene Ursula's original hair is short
and white but J gave this beauty long
white hair that's glorious like floating
around her body she looks like she's got
the smoky eye look down and she's ready
to roll the Seas we have to admit that
we'd love to see this impressive version
of Ursula in the actual movie Maleficent
from Sleeping Beauty Maleficent is the
main
antagonize of 1959 Sleeping Beauty and
her character was so popular Disney gave
her her very own live-action movie in
2014
Maleficent is the one that's responsible
for all misfortune in the kingdom
she's cold-hearted mysterious and
vengeful her looks are some of the most
extreme looks we've seen in a female
Disney villain and they only highlight
her ruthless attitude Maleficent has
very unusual mint skin a slender body
covered with a large cloak a pointy chin
and two black horns on her head this is
what Maleficent would look like if she
got a makeover this image belongs to
Kristen Reeves and she did a fantastic
job at showing a different side of this
Disney villain of course the horns are
still there so we can imagine her desire
for revenge didn't go away her character
also appeared in the popular TV show
once upon a time as well as well as the
movie descendants
she's also featured in many video games
and it's safe to say she's one of the
most popular and influential villains
out there when Maleficent the movie came
out in 2014 he received a lot of praise
for the varied representation of female
characters in the movie so in a way
Maleficent really is using her vengeful
powers for good Oh sort of Captain Hook
from Peter Pan and last but not least
it's everyone's favorite time fearing
captain that's on a mission to take out
Peter Pan
Captain Hook the world's most famous
crook Captain Hook is one of those
characters that would give you instant
fear if you'd ever seen him in real life
he's incredibly persuasive
short-tempered and dishonest he's
dressed like the typical captain of a
pirate ship and has long black hair thin
mustache and a hook on his left hand
although he's never up to any good
Captain Hook does have a soft side he is
afraid of time because he's afraid of
getting old
J the artist managed to capture his best
features check out those piercing eyes
and that mysterious look we love it
Captain Hook is also a popular character
and was heavily featured in the 2003
live-action version of Peter Pan you can
find him in video games and other TV
shows like once upon a time where you
can learn how he lost his hook but don't
worry we won't spoil that for you the
truth is Captain Hook might just be our
favorite Disney villain especially now
that we've seen his beautiful side
that's it for 10 Disney villains
reimagined as beautiful don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up
subscribe to our channel and check out
15 Disney princesses reimagine
as real people see you in the next video
[Music]